vous avez peut-être vécu son décollage
en direct ce matin l'astronaute thomas
pesquet est en route pour rejoindre la
station spatiale internationale et y
vivre six mois à bord il retrouvera un
appareil d'échographie made in touraine
c'est un professeur vivant à lignières
de touraine philippaerts bay qui l'a
mise au point la nasa en a fait
l'acquisition pour assurer pour assurer
le suivi médical des cosmonautes à
distance
plus d'explications dans ce reportage
d'aurélie renault d'un côté de
l'échographe le professeur tourangeau
philippaerts bay de l'autre guidés par
le professeur l'astronaute thomas
pesquet les échographies spatiales ont
lieu régulièrement
nous sommes en 2017 et l'objectif est
d'assurer le suivi médical lors des
séjours dans l'espace un suivi qui a
lieu depuis le centre national d études
spatiales de toulouse où l'on retrouve
le professeur arbeille donc c'est ici
qu'on vient pour opérer pour téléguider
les échographies que l'on fait sur les
astronautes à partir du sol donc
derrière moi et vous avez des tas de
pupitre il y en a un qui est dédié à
l'échographie où il ya un clavier qui
commande les cobras fait une petite
manette qui commandent des moments de la
sonde
donc on fait ça ça dure à peu près une
heure on parle avec l'astronaute on le
guide
et puis on a juste l'orientation de la
sonde et on fait des enregistrements on
à petit les fonctions on fait tout
l'échographie par nos mains de retour
sur terre thomas pesquet et le
professeur se retrouvent pour de
nouveaux examens
l'étude porte sur les artères qui
subissent un traumatisme dans l'espace
elles vieillissent
c'est une découverte fortuite on
cherchait pas ça mais on s'est aperçu
qu'elle épaississe et qu'elle venait
plus rigide
donc on a dit c'est la même chose que
lorsque l'individu vieilli de 20 ans sur
terre
ah ben c'est ce qui se passe chez les
astronautes en six mois seulement quand
vous dites à des sujets normaux quand
six mois ils ont pris 20 ans en général
ils n'aiment pas beaucoup savaient pas
plaisir et on se dit il faut s'assurer
que ça revient à la normale ce qui est
vrai mais maintenant pour des voyages
plus longs il faut s'assurer que ça va
pas continuer à partir d'un certain
temps peut-être que ça ne reviendra plus
à la normale donc on est en train de
travailler sur des mesures pour empêcher
ce vieillissement en ligne de mire des
voyages beaucoup plus lointains
les mesures opérées par l'échographie du
tourangeau pourrait peut-être un jour
permettre de voyager sur la planète mars